but before the slay and the horrible
creatures that came on it take off into
the night Max comes upon it and sees one
more frightful Twist on the Christmas
stories that he's accustomed to most
cliche Christmas movies have a scene
where someone hears Santa Claus landing
on the roof with his reindeer but those
do not sound like reindeer Kampus as
usual has his own Twisted variant known
as Yul goats like many of the creatures
that assist him during the Christmas
season Yu goats have ties to ancient
Pagan religion Thor the Norse god of
thunder was said to have a chariot
pulled by these magic goats but just
like with Kampus the Christian Church
feared these creatures and declared them
as demonic Tales were spread of the
Demonic uats roaming Scandinavia for
food and scaring children like some of
the others the U goat is still a part of
some Nordic Christmas celebrations today
most notably in Sweden in the form of a
giant decorative goat made of straw that
pranksters like to try to burn down
every year the Yul goats pulling campus'
sleigh are huge aggressive monsters with
black fur ram likee horns and an
intimidating Roar